[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle de l'industrie
française en 40 ans des milliers
d'usinés ont fermé sur notre territoire
et des millions d'emplois ont été perdus
la pandémie nous a fait découvrir avec
stupeur que nous fabriquions ni masque
ni paracétamol enfin vaccin français
contrôle qu'ovide n'est toujours pas
disponible pourtant les motifs d'espoir
sont nombreux vous verrez comment cros
cole fait le pari du smartphone made in
france ou encore comment une start-up
lance la filière de la pid écologique
dans l'hexagone mais d'abord nous serons
avec jean pierre clamadieu le président
dj il nous dira comment enrayer ce
déclin pourquoi la france a de nombreux
atouts pour s'en sortir
même si les chiffres sont alarmants
l'industrie française n'est pas morte
loin de là jean pierre clamadieu bonjour
bonjour à s'y être installée vous êtes
le président benji vous publiez l'europe
à venir de l'industrie française aux
éditions du cherche midi il faut
expliquer l'industrie c'est un peu
l'histoire de votre vie vous il fait
toute votre carrière en dirigeants des
grands groupes industriels mais c'est
aussi c'est aussi intéressant une
histoire familiale vous êtes fils de
cheminot et donc vous avez été un petit
peu aux premières loges j'ai vu
l'ascension et le déclin l'industrie
française c'est vrai que j'ai gardé des
souvenirs très forts de mon enfance
alors la fois le monde cheminot je pense
que les scènes s'est fait une belle
entreprise industrielle mais aussi le
début de grandes aventures qui ont
marqué la france je reste dans le
domaine du rail le développement du tgv
mais l'avion le premier vol du concorde
le premier vol d'airbus le premier vol
d'ariane et c'est vraiment ses aventures
là qui m'ont convaincu de fait rarement
dans l'ag de gand mais maintenant le tgv
alors ça remonte effectivement mais je
crois que c'est des choses qui ont
marqué nos territoires qui ont marqué
nos villes qui ont marqué d'ailleurs
notre environnement le tgv art façonner
l'image de la de la france et est un
outil incroyable airbus est une
fantastique réussite européenne
ariane également et donc je crois que
c'est ses aventures qui m'ont convaincu
de devenir ingénieur et puis
progressivement effectivement au fil des
opportunités de carrière d'avoir la
chance de diriger deux grands groupes de
chimie successifs est aujourd'hui
présidé le conseil de j qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé à écrire ce livre vient
déclic notamment dans le livre
vous le dites l'envol de space x on est
en 2020 et là vous dites on est en train
de rater ouais parce que l'envol de ce
pays 6 au fond on pourrait dire passer
un petit peu comme ces grandes aventures
que j'évoquais ces images qui m'ont
marqué ariane concorde ou airbus la
différence d'abord c'est que ce sont des
entrepreneurs américains qui sont à
l'origine de ces de ses aventures et
puis une espèce d'une mise en forme qui
est un peu celle d'une série télévision
et qui je crois ne te donne moins envie
à nos jeunes européens de s'engager dans
cette aventure et effectivement le c'est
un des éléments qui m'a fait dire il
faut rappeler à tout le monde que
l'industrie française c'est vraiment un
des éléments qui fondent notre pays
notre culture l'avenir de notre économie
et qu'il faut l'intégrer dans un
environnement européen après quand on
regarde pardon froidement les chiffres
je sais que vous n'êtes pas fan du de ce
flot de lamentations sur le déclinisme
ambiant sur le déclassement de la france
mais pardon quand on regarde froidement
les chiffres je prends des chiffres
macroéconomiques qu'est ce qu'on a on
perd toujours quasiment des emplois
industriels le niveau de production
industrielle et plus bas qu'avant encore
une fois le co vide et notre déficit
commercial faut se boucher les oreilles
c'est 100 milliards d'euros en rythme
annuel on se dit quand même que la
situation mais son envie de rêver de
l'industrie et pas glorieuse pour le
dire gentiment n'avaient d'abord il faut
rêver et c'est effectivement parce qu'on
rencontre des difficultés qui font rêver
et je crois que sont même rentrés dans
les chiffres le fait de se promener dans
des régions traditionnellement
industrielle en france moi j'étais en
poste en région champagne ardenne au
début de haut début de ma carrière on
voit des paysages qui ont été marqués
par la désindustrialisation et les
chiffres que vous évoquez il conforte
bien sûr ce sentiment mais c'est le
moment de se dire il faut se réveiller
il faut avancer et il faut sortir d'une
forme de déclinisme et d'une vision un
peu passéistes d'une industrie qu'on
aimerait conserver dans le formol c'est
une image que je reprends aux aidants
dans ce livre pour se dire il faut y
aller il faut rêver il faut avancer il y
a devant nous des opportunités elle
commence à avoir des effets très concret
très visible qu'on veut en parler mais
comme en expliquant ce soit plus d
industrialiser que nos petits voisins
européen et j'aimerais dire la faute aux
grands maux aux grands groupes est ce
que je me trompe ou pas alors
probablement probablement la france a
cette particularité d'avoir un nombre
beaucoup plus important que nos voisins
européens de grands groupes qui sont des
leaders mondiaux et six leaders mondiaux
quand ils ont rencontré des difficultés
à la maison eh ben ils sont partis sur
d'autres territoires pour trouver les
perspectives de développement et
peut-être plus facilement que dans
d'autres pays dans lesquels il y avait
par exemple en allemagne un groupe
d'entreprises de taille moyenne qui elle
avait un ancrage territorial fort et je
pense qu'effectivement cette situation
joint peut-être à une à une difficulté
qu'on a dans notre pays de transformer
de faire évoluer parce que l'industrie
c'est un monde qui bouge sans arrêt donc
il faut il faut que les entreprises
soient l'affût de ces évolutions et puis
s'est engagé ceci a conduit à une forme
de désindustrialisation à laquelle il
faut j'en suis convaincu aujourd'hui
mettre fin on parle beaucoup de
délocalisation mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que quand on regarde les chiffres
les pertes de parts de marché de la
france en matière de commerce extérieur
ces pertes ne se font pas vis-à-vis de
la vie ne se font pas vis-à-vis de la
chine mais vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
européens et là on se dit est ce que
c'est rompre homme de coups de coût du
travail souvent pays là dans l'industrie
le coup travail c'est trop cher c'est
trop élevé les charges sociales c'est
trop élevés notamment ce qui est vrai
quand on se compare à l'allemagne mais
pas que donc je crois qu'effectivement
le coût du travail et est un sujet les
comparaisons que l'on peut être fait
les comparaisons qui ont pu être entre
la france et l'allemagne le montre cette
problématique très particulier en france
des impôts de production écart des
impôts que vous des impôts que vous
payez avant même d'avoir commencé à
gagner de l'argent commence à baisser un
petit peu différent c'est absurde il ya
eu un certain nombre de i am un certain
nombre de ruptures une difficulté à
faire travailler ensemble l'écosystème
enseignements et en partie aux
renseignements dur à tout niveau
enseignement supérieur recherche
entreprises dans certains endroits dans
certains territoires ça fonctionne bien
en france dans d'autres territoires
c'est beaucoup plus difficile et il faut
qu'on soit capable de jouer de ses
atouts pour repartir dans une démarche
ambitieuse et conquérante mais on perd
des abonnés par rapport encore une fois
aux italiens aux espagnols aux allemands
mon sujet il est là en fait oui mais en
même temps sur certains sujets reprenons
le cas d'airbus un exemple
extraordinaire de compass 2
collaboration franco-allemande qui
permet de créer un leader européen qui
est en train de devenir l'acteur
dominant du marché de l'aviation
commerciale regardons ce qui est en
train de se passer sur l'industrie
automobile ford transformation véhicules
électriques tout d'un coup une idée
germe en disant mais on peut pas passer
à côté des sujets des batteries et parce
qu'effectivement dans un véhicule
électrique une part importante de laval
airbus de avait fait est fait autour des
batteries et alors c'est pas un airbus
de la batterie mais c'est de très
nombreux projets aujourd'hui qui se
localise sur notre territoire et la
france est plutôt bien placé aujourd'hui
pour accueillir un certain nombre de ces
projets pour fabriquer ce composant
essentiel de la voiture de demain donc
il y a décidé d'attribuer viennent
d'asie et en asie corée chine jacques
allant jusqu'à 90% absolument mais là il
ya eu cette idée quand même temps que la
voiture électrique se développer elle se
développe du fait de normes qui seront
imposées par par l'europe on allait
s'attaquer à ce sujet et faire en sorte
de le localiser en europe une production
de batteries c'est un symbole qui est
fort et je crois qu'il faut que vous et
ce cri que j'essaie de pousser
aujourd'hui nous faisons il y a un
avenir pour l'industrie la vision d'une
société post industrielle que certains
de mes collègues d'ailleurs industriels
ont pu porter à cessange usine est
effectivement un trône alcatel verdel
disant ceux de ma société sans usine non
c'est pas la réalité la réalité c'est
une société dans laquelle on a besoin d'
usine pour fabriquer les produits de
demain et puis on est aujourd'hui en
europe face à un enjeu majeur qui est la
transition énergétique et là je pense
qu'il ya une opportunité massif pour
l'industrie française et européenne
c'est juste après il faut aussi admettre
qu'on a un problème de compétence à le
coût du travail on a parlé avec un peu
rapidement parce que c'est un sujet qui
est qui est assez bien connus mais on
imprime de compétences haussier en
france on manque d'ingénieurs on n'a pas
ces techniciens et sa touche en fait
tous les métiers l'industrie qui sont en
tension voire en pénurie et là on se dit
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'il faut qui
plus d'étudiants qui fasse plus de
cursus scientifiques les garçons et les
filles aussi d'ailleurs alors votre
question résume bien la résumer à un
groupe comme angie il a besoin de
techniciens pour faire pour entretenir
des installations de production
d'énergie ou de chauffage ou d'air
conditionné et il a besoin d'ingénieurs
de très haut niveau pour développer des
projets innovants dans l'ensemble de
cette chaîne on a des difficultés de
recrutement aujourd'hui on cherche à y
apporter des réponses pour pour les pour
les métiers de technicien s'est souvent
nous qui prenons l'initiative de créer
des centres de formation d'apprentis des
centres de formation en alternance qui
permettent d'attirer des jeunes et de
les former vers ces métiers dans
lesquels il ya des opportunités et pour
ce qui est des ingénieurs oui nous avons
aujourd'hui des difficultés à attirer
les meilleurs dans des cursus
scientifique et technique comment ils
ont envie aux jeunes de travailler dans
l'industrie
c'est un petit peu ce que j'ai essayé de
faire très très modestement en écrivant
ce en écrivant ce petit essai et en
partageant ses idées coup on les
mobilise en leur expliquant que
l'industrie à une partie des réponses
aux enjeux de la planète d'aujourd'hui
je pense que le canton par le changement
climatique au joueur donné du sens c'est
quand on parle changement climatique
aujourd'hui un jeune je vois avec mes
deux filles
on vous on les réveille on leur dit on
leur montre qu'il y a effectivement
quelque chose à faire on leur montre que
de travailler dans l'entreprise
travaille dans l'industrie a du sens et
permettent contribuer à répondre à ces
défis et je crois qu'il faut que
l'industrie
s'expriment les industriels s'exprime
avec force pour attirer les meilleurs
talents chez eux après il faut pas nier
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites du
point de vue politique par les autorités
par les pouvoirs publics ces dernières
années pour l'industriel ces baisses
d'impôts de production 10 milliards
d'euros beaucoup réclament 30 ou 40
après je passerai un déficit public le
permettent mais ça notre sujet mais il
ya eu la réforme de la formation
professionnelle de l'apprentissage tout
ça va dans le bon sens même si c'est
tardif tout ça va dans le bon sens on a
vraiment franchi une étape sur
l'apprentissage là aujourd'hui les le
nombre de jeunes en formation en
alternance est en train d'exploser et ça
c'est très bien il faut qu'on continue à
censurer à tous les niveaux de niveau
technicien jusqu'à des niveaux de
formation supérieure réforme de la
formation professionnelle très utile
impôts de production je pense que là
aussi on a franchi une étape même s'il
reste beaucoup de choses à faire pour
retrouver tout simplement la parité avec
la parité avec certains de nos
concurrents européens il faut aussi bien
su rester attractif que le site france
reste attractif il est de plus en plus
pour le coup dans les enquêtes et quand
on voit
le géant américain des semi-conducteurs
qui veut fabriquer en europe pour 30
milliards d'euros des puces
électroniques dse les grandes guerres
des chips comme on dit en anglais y met
son usine en allemagne il met son
laboratoire de recherche en france nous
on a un peu le lot de consolation et
finalement la production la partie
industrielle de production se retrouve
en allemagne alors je crois pas que la
recherche soit le lot de consolation au
contraire un c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est très important et c'est
vrai que la france à la fois par la
qualité des compétences je disais tout à
l'heure mais l'usiné là bas l'usiné là
bas pas assez d'ingénieurs mais beaucoup
d'ingénieurs de très très haut niveau un
système de crédit d'impôt recherche qui
est particulièrement attractif ça ça
attire les sounders mais il faut que les
usines deviennent aussi chez nous
certaines viennent chez nous on a vu
beaucoup de projets annoncés c'est
annoncées ces derniers mois qui montre
que le site france retrouve de
l'attractivité on peut pas gagner tous
les projets mais il faut qu'on se batte
et qu'on montre à nos collègues
industriels étrangers mais aussi aux
grands comptes français que le site
france est un site attractif aujourd'hui
l'europe vous l'avez évoqué jean pierre
clamadieu qui est à l'avant garde de
cette transition énergétique on a des
cartes à jouer de l'industrie française
doit en profiter l'imageur de ce café
angie mais pas seulement alors que et
entend j'en ai je dit ça et en même
temps
les hélices et les mâts d éoliennes ne
sont pas fabriqués en france alors ça
c'est 90 a corrigé aujourd'hui sur
l'éolien marin en particulier on a fait
un gros effort pour que
l'industrialisation sur terre de ses
produits pour l'industrialisation de ses
produits puissent se faire effectivement
pu se faire effectivement france alors
non il ya une carte à jouer en tout cas
une carte à jouer et est à nouveau ne
posons pas la france et les autres pays
européens je pense que c'est vraiment la
plaque européenne qui a vocation à
redevenir un acteur majeur en matière
industrielle entre les différentes
régions du monde et quand on parle
projet moyens il ya un sujet que j'ai
vraiment qui me tient très à coeur ainsi
l'hydrogène je suis persuadé que dans la
transition énergétique qu'engage
l'europe aujourd'hui l'hydrogène un rôle
essentiel à jouer parce que c'est une
sorte de second fluide énergétique aux
côtés de l'électricité mais qui a des
caractéristiques particulières très
intéressante le fait qu'ils se stoppe
très facilement le fait que c'est un gaz
donc une forte densité d hydrogène bien
sûr l'hydrogène verts il est produit à
partir d'électricité renouvelable il
peut être consommé dans des
installations industrielles
il peut être consommé dans des moyens de
transport qui vont du train à l'avion en
passant par le bateau houleux où le
poids lourd et l'europe pourrait être le
premier la première région du monde à
développer un réseau de production de
transport de stockage est distinct du
classement du thon rouge albert avec une
place importante pour la france il y à
des groupes comme angie qui ont des
installations de stockage de gaz qui
pourraient être utilisés pour ce kit
hydrogène il y à des canalisations bien
sûr qui pourrait contribuer à un axe
européen hors sud sur ce sujet et puis
il ya des compétences et des savoir
faire airbus travaille aujourd'hui sur
un avion à hydrogène la sncf s'intéresse
à l'hydrogène comme substitut au diesel
pour c'est pour ces engins de pour ses
engins de de manoeuvre et et ceux qui
tirent des trains sur les lignes qui ne
sont pas électrifiés cma-cgm sur le
maritime est aussi très en avance dans
la réflexion sur ces sujets ce sont mes
opportunités pour relancer un d'une
carte à jouer sur ce sujet mais sur bien
d'autres l'airbus des batteries on en
parlait tout à l'heure le développement
de technologies moi j'étais impressionné
par l'investissement d'arcelormittal en
france pour fabriquer de l'acier par un
procédé qu'on appelle de réduction
directe donc en utilisant d'ailleurs là
aussi que l'hydrogène mais sans émission
de co2 associées il y a énormément de
projets création d'un jour d'une
scission en attendant ploie qui sont
créateurs d'emplois est ce que pour un
emploi industriel j'ai pu chiffres en
tête ces trois ou quatre on est à trois
quatre emplois induits voilà en fait
l'emploi industriel il a un caractère
très structurant entendu dire dès le
début d'ailleurs ça ouais et j'ai fait
une petite tribune il ya quelques
semaines pour montrer que dans le bassin
d'emploi de dunkerque dunkerque on a
l'image effectivement d'un damas un
emploi qui a beaucoup souffert dans la
période de désindustrialisation
des années des années 80 sur dunkerque
investissements massifs annoncés dans
les batteries plusieurs milliers
d'emplois à la clé arcelormittal il
investit lui plusieurs milliards d'euros
pour transformer son aciérie en aciérie
en réaction directe et angie vient avec
un projet de production d'hydrogène et
puis intéressant en combinaison avec
arcelormittal est un acteur américain
produit produisons un projet pour
produire ce qu'on appelle des i fiul
c'est à dire des carburants complètement
décarbonés en utilisant de l'hydrogène
et du co2 produit par arcelormittal et
ça c'est des projets qui font d'une zone
comme celle de dunkerque une zone
d'expérimentation de ce qu'est la
transition énergétique et son impact
concret dans la création d'emplois il ya
une procédure à l'intérieur d'une
opportunité tout comme digital canton
voulions comprendre et digital c'est
aussi une chance pour l'industrie alors
le digital est essentiel pour
l'industrie le digital et tu ne vous
l'avait expérimenté technologies
digitales les technologies liées aux
données est quelque chose qui est en
train de changer la donne dans
l'industrie je le raconte d'ailleurs
demi effectivement dans mon petit livre
au début j'étais un homme chimiste chez
solvay un peu sceptique ambiance ça fait
longtemps qu'on utilise des calculateurs
qui permettent de piloter nos procédés
et puis un jour des jeunes ingénieurs
sont venus me rencontrer au hasard d'une
visite et me dire nous on pourrait
vraiment faire beaucoup plus si vous
vous donniez un tout petit peu de moyens
on a identifié des logiciels des
algorithmes comme on dit qui permettrait
de mieux piloter nos outils je leur ai
dit pourquoi pas et j'ai été étonné du
résultat dire qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya des algorithmes qui
tournait avant sur des médias
calculateur et donc était pas du tout
accessible en milieu industriel qui
tourne aujourd'hui sur des ordinateurs
qui ont des puissances de calcul qui
sont accessibles à tous qui permet de
bien mieux gérer nos outils industriels
je le vois aujourd'hui chez angie ou nos
parcs de renouvelables par exemple dont
parcs éoliens sont eux bénéficient eux
aussi de ce que le big data pour
reprendre la terminologie qu'on emploie
souvent peut apporter en optimisation de
fonctionnement et donc oui digital
transition énergétique et industrie ça
va vraiment très bien en place là-dedans
dans l'écosystème pour les start up
elles sont là aussi très utiles les
algorithmes que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure que mes ingénieurs de solvay ont
utilisé il était promise été développé
par une start up américaine les start up
c'est un moyen de développement très
rapide et efficace c'est une source
d'inspiration pour les entreprises on a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui créent ici ou
là dans l'eure dans leurs sièges sociaux
des petits coins start up dans lesquels
on essaie de reproduire à une échelle à
une échelle modeste là l'efficacité et
la rapidité du travail qu'on est capable
de faire dans une dans une start up et
je pense que ces écosystèmes
c'est ce qu'ils permettent à l'industrie
de se renforcer et de se développer donc
on finit là dessus il ya de nombreuses
raisons de croire au renouveau de
l'industrie française même si encore une
fois par dans les chiffres macro sont
peu sont peu encourageants on cesse tout
juste de détruire des engins vous dis la
france je pense que les chiffres macro
ils montrent qu'on est en train de
toucher le fond de là le vent de
l'arrivée seconde s'anime et moi je suis
convaincu qu'on est en train de repartir
qu'on voit des signaux concrets qui
montrent qu'on repart je pense qu'il
faut de l'ambition je pense qu'il faut
des entrepreneurs dans les grands
groupes dans les petites structures
comme les start up je pense qu'il faut
aussi des pouvoirs publics qui nous
guident les grands projets que
j'évoquais sur la transition énergétique
et climat lié à ces deux font plaisir
d'ailleurs ya assez d'argent public
d'investissement aujourd'hui je sais que
le sujet je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'investissements ya de l'argent public
il ya beaucoup d'argent privé qui est
prête à s'investir sur des projets qui
font sens mais il nous faut un récit
comme on dit il nous faut une ambition
il faut des projets et ceci conduit à
naturellement aligner les ressources et
les ambitions et oui moi je suis
convaincu qu'il ya un avenir pour
l'industrie française dans l'europe
raisonnons europe c'est vraiment
l'échelle pertinente
pour pouvoir jouer dans la compétition
mondiale allez merci être passés nous
voir à jean pierre clamadieu d'enclos
président d' angie merci à vous merci
beaucoup tiens et si on produisait des
smartphones en france c'est le pari de
crosse colle une pme d'aix-en-provence
qui va rapatrier sa production tenez
vous bien depuis la chine magne l'aigre
depuis les années 70 la france est le
pays de l'union européenne qui s'est le
plus d industrialiser elle représentait
25 % de la richesse nationale il ya 40
ans contre 13 aujourd'hui deux millions
et demi d'emplois ont été supprimés à
cause de la fuite des entreprises à
l'étranger
mais la crise sanitaire le prix du fret
multiplier par dix les pénuries de
matières premières ou encore la guerre
en ukraine pourrait bien pousser les
dirigeants d'entreprise à revoir dans un
avenir proche leur stratégie
les événements sont tellement importants
depuis deux ans que les entreprises sont
obligées de réfléchir sur une adaptation
qu'elles doivent mettre en place plutôt
que de dépendre d'un seul fournisseur
sans doute faut-il que j'envisage une
manière de pouvoir passer d'un
fournisseur à l'autre
est-ce que je peux pas me ménager des
circuits un peu plus court tous ces
défis qui viennent en même temps qui
viennent percuter en même temps nous
oblige les entreprises à repenser leur
manière de produire
et justement une entreprise française
dont le siège est basé à aix en provence
a décidé de changer son fusil d épaule
il s'agit de crosse cool les
spécialistes des smartphones ultra
résistant
sapeur bull est mort au feu
ils ont été imaginés pour les forces de
l'ordre les professionnels du btp ou
encore les amateurs de sports extrêmes
sur le premier produit on a on n'a pas
de souci à une ou restent donc les
autres a testé depuis 2009 cette
entreprise fabrique ses smartphones en
chine pour les revendre en europe mais
en 2019 tout s'effondre avec l'aco vide
deux ans plus tard le constat est amer
nous avons mis de côté plus de 30
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
sur cette période ce qui a fortement
impacté les comptes de l'entreprise en
temps de crise une entreprise qui
fabrique à 12000 kilomètres de ses
clients reste-t-elle compétitive pour le
savoir
roscoe la rapatrier il ya un an un
maillon de sa chaîne de production ce
laboratoire ou plutôt cette salle de
torture pour smartphones
on externalise essai test chez notre
partenaire industriel qui est localisé
en chine et là on a on a c'est un
premier pas en fait vers
l'industrialisation en france avec la
maîtrise de la conception il à la
vérification des tests
avant validation du produit un premier
pas car cyril le pdg ne compte pas
s'arrêter là il voit les choses en grand
et sur le trottoir d'en face il vient
d'acquérir cette hangar alors là on est
en neuf ans les locaux et aux alentours
de 2000 m² il a d'ailleurs ses entrées à
l'elysée depuis que manuel macro est
venue sur son stand lors du congrès des
sapeurs pompiers à marseille le
président était venu pour soutenir les
entreprises dans leur démarche
d'industrialisation
il faut se prémunir et désormais on sait
pas ce qui se passera à l'avenir nous
devons intégrer un modèle industriel
nous permettant de pouvoir pallier
justement à ces problématiques ou du
jour au lendemain un continent se se
ferme et ont surtout dans une situation
compliquée donc l'idée c'est de dire
nous devons être le plus autonome
possible nous devons maîtriser au plus
proche la chaîne et pouvoir anticiper un
certain nombre de d'événements qui
pourra arriver grâce à cette nouvelle
usine l'entreprise pourra assembler les
différents composants mais cette ligne
de production française ne lui permettra
pas d'être totalement indépendante
l'ensemble des composants proviennent de
france mais aussi d'asie et ça on ne
pourra pas y échapper mais il n'y a
aucune industrie qui intègre de
l'électronique qui peut se passer l'osi
cros cole va apporter depuis l'autre
bout du monde non pas des centaines de
milliers de téléphones mais de petits
composants très léger sur le plan
écologique l'entreprise va donc
considérablement réduire son empreinte
carbone
si le cas de crosse cole semble bien
parti pour fonctionner la majorité des
industriels sont sceptiques regardons
les chiffres jusqu'à présent il ya
toujours beaucoup plus d'investissement
fait part des entreprises françaises à
l'étranger qu'il n'ya d'investissements
d'entreprises étrangères en france ou
d'entreprises françaises qui rapatrie de
la production en france au delà de la
compétitivité les entreprises qui
souhaiteraient renault qu'alizé leur
activité en france craignent le manque
de main d'oeuvre on se rend compte que
l'histoire ça importe quand votre
histoire industrielle elle est faite
d'une division par plus de 2 du nombre
d'emplois que vous avez dans votre pays
eh bien vous êtes entré dans un
mécanisme un peu mortifère où vous
n'avez plus les instituts de formation
en capacité de créer les compétences qui
seront embauchés ensuite dans les
industries pour aider les entreprises à
devenir les leaders de l'innovation de
demain le gouvernement a prévu dans son
plan de relance une enveloppe de 34
milliards donc 720 millions sur trois
ans pour financer des projets
industriels avec cuisine à la craie
[Musique]
cros comme on vient de le voir fait le
pari de fabriquer des smartphones en
france tiens et si on produisait aussi
nos propres pilon jour et militant belge
alors l'idée c'est de faire évidemment
un geste pour la planète parce qu'il
s'agit de piles qui sont des piles écolo
a là on parle de piles boutons vous
savez ce sont toutes celles que l'on
trouve dans les appareils de faible
puissance a peut être les montres les
petits livres sonores pour les enfants
ou encore les petites appareils à usage
unique type test de grossesse ce sont
des pigeons jetables extrêmement
polluant fabriqués à base de lithium est
malheureusement malgré un effort de
collecte 97% d'entre elles finissent à
la poubelle soit 15 milliards depuis de
piles boutons qui polluent à nos sols
chaque année et il ya urgence à jérémy
puisque quand on connaît surtout l'essor
fulgurant de tous ces objets
électroniques pour cela mais c'est avec
de plus en plus l'internet des objets à
saint vite dans notre quotidien ça peut
être dans nos vêtements connectés dans
les emballages de nos colis dans les
capteurs de notre maison ou de notre
voiture et ce n'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter et c'est justement pour
répondre à ce défi que la start up
grenobloise bf ci a conçu une biopile
agra mi chemin entre eux puis entre une
pile et une batterie après plusieurs
années de recherche au sein du cnrs elle
s'appelle bio cellules et elle
révolutionne complètement l'univers des
pieds alors ce qui est très surprenant
c'est son aspect les films comme du
petit cigare et bien justement figurez
vous qu'elle est en papier cette pile
alors elle est allée en fait il ya une
alternance de cette couche de papier
carbone et de cellulose pour être précis
et entre ces couches vous trouvez du
glucose donc du sucre des électrodes en
carbone des enzymes et puis également
sur le si un petit réservoir avec un
fluide à l'intérieur ça pourrait être de
l'eau du sang ou l'uriné s'il s'agit
d'un test de grossesse vous voyez tout
ça est très naturel il n'y a absolument
aucun plastique okamoto aucune substance
toxique est donc une fille qui est fait
en papier et en sucre produit de
l'électricité pas une blague à la rampe
salaires est très facile à utiliser vous
aviez vous avez juste à appuyer sur le
réservoir le fluide est alors envoyé sur
les enzymes ça va créer une oxydation au
contact de l'eau l'enzyme transforme en
fait lui causent en glucose lactones qui
va créer des électrons des électrons qui
vont ensuite pouvoir être utilisé pour
créer du courant via une réduction
d'oxygène en eau incroyable tout ce que
la durée de vie de cette ville ça va
dépendre de l'objet ça peut aller de
quelques minutes pour un test de
grossesse à quelques mois et puis
concernant ses capacités de stockage
c'est intéressant car si elle n'est pas
activée pendant les dix on dit moi et
bien ne va perdre que 4% de sa puissance
que quand même pas mal puisqu'on parle
de sa durée de vie tient quid de sa de
sa fin de vie justement est ce qu'elle
est recyclable alors le papier lui pas
de problème on sait on sait le recycler
en revanche là où ça coince et pour les
électrodes et électro nation en carbone
c'est donc du charbon c'est quelque
chose de naturel mais pour l'instant ne
s'est pas de recycler les équipes de bf
600 sur le pont pourraient s'y trouver
une solution si elle n'y arrive pas pas
trop l'âme car il faut savoir que tout
c'est sous ces matériaux que ce soit le
papier le carbone sur des éléments
naturels et donc ils sont absolument
neutre pour l'environnement c'est une
innovation qui est carrément bluffante
emilie mais mais mais elles nous
viennent start-ups qui est très bien
sauf que notre miss aujourd'hui traite
de l'industrie des frênes comme vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure avec votre
invité le salut de notre industrie on
l'a vu il passe par le numérique et
l'écologie et c'est vrai que ça ne
pourra pas se faire sans les start up
qui offre en quelque sorte des briques
technologiques aux industriels pour se
réinventer donc elles ont tous leur rôle
à jouer ces startups et où en est-on
justement de l'industrialisation
justement de bien alors on en est à deux
ans d'existence et elle a déjà noué des
partenariats stratégiques avec des
grands noms de l'industrie comme
stmicroelectronics
elle produit actuellement 1000 bio
cellule par jour pour des clients dont
elle préfère taire le nom pour l'instant
et puis l'année prochaine elle a prévu
de passer la vitesse supérieure avec
l'acquisition d'une machine plus
puissante qui ne qui permettra de
produire un million de piles par jour en
france mais aussi à l'international
voilà en france surtout merci emilie
pourvu que ça dure les missions qui rend
les co-responsables c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que ça vous a plu
magazine à voir ou revoir évidemment sur
public sénat ya du replay sur
publicsenat.fr rendez vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]